I could have shown you 400
000 roughly compilations of media lying
about things and demonizing people and
everything else but we got this one it
mostly focuses on the uh the Canadian
truckers you may remember them
Ottawa is being besieged by a group of
anti-doo anything about covid truckers
called the freedom Convoy a so-called
Freedom Convoy so-called Freedom Convoy
of truckers the police chief is calling
it a Nationwide Insurrection driven by
Madness this city is under siege they
are now calling it an occupation a
threat to democracy an Insurrection
sedition sedition Insurrection a threat
to democracy we've heard it called a
nationwide Insurrection this is kind of
our Insurrection by air horn moment so I
think it's part of the globalization of
trumpism yes a cult yes it is residents
say they feel like hostages there hasn't
been as much violence as some had
perhaps projected but that does not
necessarily mean that it has been
peaceful alarming situation there in
Ottawa the first part of that obviously
was the truckers and the way that they
frame the truckers right they're all
racist and bigoted and they remember
Justin Trudeau literally called them
transphobes that's why he said they were
out on the street what's also
interesting did you notice a couple
times those uh journalists called it the
so-called Freedom Convoy it was called
the freedom Convoy the freedom Convoy
people called it the freedom Convoy uh
but however when we had this don't say
gay thing here which was not called
don't say gay right it was hb1887 or
something like that uh no one called it
the so-called don't say gay they just
labeled it this the don't say gay so
these little tricks that that they do
that is that is so important for you to
be able to see